ho deciso di cambiare io sono Antonio io
sono co founder e ci finiva solofficer
della Evolution È un'azienda di Molfetta
in provincia di Bari ho deciso di
cambiare la prima parte dello speech
perché sul concetto di vertigini vi
racconto un attimo la nostra storia a
livello aziendale in questo momento noi
siamo tra i primi cinque partner nel
mondo sia di Microsoft che di Meta in
queste tecnologie ma Siamo di Molfetta
non siamo né di New York né di Milano
nell'altra parte e la nostra storia è un
po' particolare
perché
nasciamo da un settore completamente
diverso da quello che mette verso Noi
facevamo ferramenta non mi faccio la
domanda Da dove proviene perché era
complicatissimo da capire però la logica
non è mai cambiata avevamo brevettato
circa sei anni fa a otto anni fa una
sala cinema da dare ai falegnami i quali
presentavano le con un sistema carico un
sistema di progettazione le cucine a
dimensioni reali su un proiettore tale
che il cliente quando andavo da loro
perché non riuscivano a presentar nulla
vedevano questo schermo cinematografico
alla cucina queste questo modello di
business è piaciuto molto da un'azienda
tedesca che ci copre di soldi e lo
vendiamo da questi soldi Abbiamo deciso
di rivestirli dove li rivestiamo perché
eravamo sempre appassionati di diciamo
di tecnologia Ma perché questa cosa
fatta per rifare gli ami non può andar
bene anche in altri settori quindi chi
di voi ha fatto gli arredamenti
Ultimamente o l'arredamento di casa
ultimamente immaginate di poter vedere
in casa
l'intero arredamento a livello
olografico in una stanza in una casa
vuota
quindi immaginate di poter dire vorrei
fare Casa Moderna bene però la casa è
vuota diventa un gran casino immaginasse
perché il problema è l'immaginazione
rispetto alla visualizzazione
il nostro CEO Antonella notte
gli dicono un articolo Repubblica
in prima pagina come donna manager
arriva un'email di Pasquale Natuzzi il
quale praticamente non possono due
eccellenze e pulirsi non collaborare
insieme per Natuzzi facciamo il primo
Store di 40 metri a New York Anzi a
Tottenham corta a Londra Dove In 40
metri i clienti potevano vedere tutti i
legali collezione divani a livello
olografico Cioè quindi uno poteva
scegliere e tutti i divani potevi poter
vederli direttamente dentro lo Store e
dentro casa
questo progetto è
piaciuto molto Microsoft e ci chiama il
la persona che ha preso il posto dei
Bill Gates che e Satana della e mandiamo
come in short list nell'evento più
importante al mondo a Las Vegas che si
chiama Microsoft inspire lunghe il
Cecino meno come partner dell'anno a
livello a livello internazionale
la cosa carina è stata il momento in cui
ci hanno intervistato prima di salire
sul palco Scusate Qual è la vostra
origine e noi abbiamo detto hardware
Largo non doppio significato in inglese
e si è compiuta che ferramenta quando ci
hanno chiesto quando ci hanno chiesto e
che cosa vendevate IBM no cerniere guide
per cassette ed è stata la cosa che c'è
molto il giocatore molto molto
particolare perché nessuno di loro si
aspettava una cosa di questo tipo perché
vi dico questo
perché l'innovazione Noi abbiamo la
nostra storia ora stiamo facendo anche
dell'altro con l'intelligenza generativa
ha avuto un filo conduttore La vostra
ossessione è di essere dei generatori di
profitto dei nostri clienti ci aiutare
loro a vendere di più quindi così come
il falegname lo abbiamo aiutato a
presentarsi meglio altrettanto la mia
foto per adulti l'abbiamo fatto proprio
nell'ambito anche museale ora neanche
nell'ambito scolastico Infatti farò lo
speech in particolare per i professori
che si accingono diciamo a
dover spiegare magari una lezione di
storia e magari invitare Napoleone
Bonaparte in classe e fargli raccontare
la storia che può sembrare una cosa
assurda ma realmente queste cose si
possono fare
Come si fa però innovazione concreta
Come si fa questa cosa Come si posso
fare partendo da Molfetta perché il
punto è anche la location per me alle
volte è più difficile spiegare dove è
Molfetta che non coloro che facciamo
Cosa vedete qui in tabelle è nata
tabellina
come
è una tabellina del 5 no tutto bene
com'è
Non ho capito
Peccato che ho fatto nove cose corrette
vi state concentrando solo sull'errore
No no questo è un classico e non inspiri
che succede
la nostra politica è quella Noi abbiamo
tutti i giovani tutti i ragazzi tra di
me
che hanno fatto rientrare destro sui
famosi Cervelli in Fuga stanno
ritornando tutti quanti e l'approccio
che diamo è la sperimentazione e la
sperimentazione non ci si può a un
ragazzino di 23 anni 24 anni digli hai
sbagliato quindi questa tabellina io la
interpreti un altro modo hai fatto nuove
cose corrette non sto dicendo bugie
quindi è sbagliata solo una vediamo di
correggere la prossima volta il per fare
innovazione reale e per fare in modo che
questi ragazzi possono realmente
esprimersi quindi senza avere
quell'incubo del voto sbagliato del voto
del 4 del 3 Probabilmente se l'approccio
cambia Diciamo che avete questo è uguale
eh non è che ho detto che avete detto
una cosa sbagliata dicendo che il 5X5
non è uno ci mancherebbe abbiamo fatto
nuove cose corrette quindi nel momento
in cui si deve applicare questo tipo di
Concetto all'interno di un'azienda
quindi il concetto magico che è successo
a noi è proprio questo tipo di approccio
mentale
il passaggio di fare in modo che le
persone possono sperimentare e in che
modo si sperimenta non ci Bisogna
conoscere le tecnologie ma non è la
tecnologia che fa la differenza e il
modo con cui vengono applicate le
tecnologie e può sembra strano in un
video che vedrete
che vedrete tra poco uno dice È
bellissima la l'extender reality
Ma la parte più importante non è la
tecnologia E lo storytelling la
sceneggiatura
dell'esperienza che si fa attraverso le
tecnologie c'è conta più per noi il lo
scenore Noi abbiamo delle sceneggiatori
che scrivono le storie dell'esperienza
D'Acquisto di vendita e successivamente
le realizziamo noi ci i miei ragazzi si
arrabbiano Praticamente siamo dei
Muratori digitali Cioè se e la storia
che conta di più rispetto alla
tecnologia stessa Quindi così
l'argomento ideale di immaginate un
cellulare davanti al cellulare mi
fuoriesce un ologramma Quindi io vedo il
divano di casa La casa è vuota vedo il
divano posizionato all'interno della
casa Questo è l'argomento i reality se
indosso un visore
vedo l'argomento ideale dice che il loro
grafia la vedo Praticamente in maniera
io vedo sia l'aspetto reale che
l'aspetto diciamo digitale la Virtual
reality è quella completamente immersiva
cioè io entro in un mondo completamente
cieco d'accordo dove vado a ricostruiamo
non è che una cosa è migliore una cosa
peggiore se devo vedere un cantiere di 4
km quadrati non posso vederli in una
stanza piccola è impossibile li devo
entrare in un concetto di Virtual
reality Se invece io devo vedere un
divano all'interno della casa è chiaro
che l'argomento ideale io la mixels
uno non volevamo sostituire la lezione
fisica in nessun modo l'incubo alle
volte Ah ma il digitale e sostituire il
filtro no Vogliamo solo dare i super
poteri i professori se avete messo Chi
ha visto Iron Man più tardi superpoteri
e professori alle professoresse In che
modo se qualcuno mi chiede a Luna qui
Chiaramente abbiamo scherzato su questo
voi la potete portare in classe ma è
sempre lezione fisica solo che è
impossibile portare la luna in classe è
impossibile portare il Colosseo in
classe è impossibile portare il cuore
umano che batte in classe è impossibile
ci sono alcune situazioni che voi non
potete fare in classe
in questo modo invece solo il prof ai
superpoteri tutti gli altri doni vedono
la lezione con i tablet
e il prof con un visore trasparente
olografico c'è proprio con i gesti con
le Gesture quelli tipo Iron Man
Visualizza degli oggetti olografici che
è impossibile da portare normalmente in
aula perché non è che vuole prendere il
Colosseo dei portali in aula la vedo un
po' complicata
e qui è cambiata completamente come
vedete la tecnologia è sempre la stessa
ciò che è cambiato e lo storytelling c'è
proprio la sceneggiatura c'è cosa se ne
fa della tecnologia E sono successe cose
carine perché abbiamo fatto in modo che
il professore venisse visto dalla dagli
alunni con i superpoteri tecnologici Io
dico il rispetto tecnologico che
attualmente non ha perché gli alunni
pensano di essere più innovativi a
livello tecnologico in questo modo
abbiamo un po' cambiato i paradigmi
Infatti come il ministero ci hanno
adottato questo tipo di discorso Grazie
proprio a questo tipo di approccio
è migliore vi faccio vedere questo video
in che modo si può applicare si possono
applicare le tecnologie in un concetto
proprio di reperto storico ho sentito
prima un collega che parlava di Federico
II di Svevia Ma questo è un'esperienza
che viene fatto Al castello a casa del
Monte
dove praticamente
si entra dentro o si è storici
chiaramente Ci mancherebbe ossia dentro
si vedono otto Mura bellissime ma alla
fine non si può far nulla Non puoi
mettere un quadro non puoi far nulla
cioè era tutto bloccato insieme è stato
fatto un bellissimo lavoro pubblico
privato abbiamo ricostruito ma tutto a
livello olografico ciò che era il Castel
del Monte prima ma con una persona che
Federico di Svevia che raccontava la
storia a livello olografico
possiamo andare il video vado avanti
[Musica]
Castel del Monte
sito UNESCO dal 1996 e straordinario
capolavoro dell'architettura medievale
il monumento apre le porte alle
tecnologie intelligenti per offrire
innovative esperienze di visita
Che renderanno Questo immenso patrimonio
culturale fruibile a tutti in ogni parte
del mondo
la visita Un site diventa Smart e si
arricchisce di contenuti in realtà
aumentata narrati dall'avatar
dell'imperatore Federico II
[Musica]
con la mixed reality e i visori
Microsoft ololens 2
il museo diventa sigill
e si apre a collegamenti in diretta
streaming tra la guida turistica e i
visitatori a casa una visita interattiva
supportata dalla connettività wi-fi del
castello per apprezzare ogni dettaglio
architettonico con gemelli digitali e
testi multilingua
[Musica]
per lasciarsi emozionare dal potere
narrante della mixed reality che fonde i
dati reali scenari digitali e inedite
ipotesi ricostruttive
[Musica]
per esplorare con gli occhi della guida
l'armonia e la perfezione di questa
monumentale opera della cultura
umanistica
e ammirare straordinari modelli
olografici in scala reale animati ad
altissima definizione
[Musica]
porta così la storia l'architettura e
l'arte di Castel del Monte in tutto il
mondo
ed emoziona anche i visitatori sul posto
qui la parte più importante non è stata
la nostra è stata dagli storici che ci
hanno descritto scrupolosamente ciò che
era se noi abbiamo fatto veramente i
muratori digitali io scherzo nel dire
questa parola ma realmente così se lì ci
mettevamo noi a fare delle invenzioni
facevamo la più grande fesseria del
mondo Quindi anche queste nuovi tipi di
di
lavoro cioè gli storici che abbiamo
coinvolto e come il metaverso Noi non
c'entriamo una mazza come attraverso
invece non è stato così perché comunque
lo storytelling la storia va raccontata
anche la sorella studia e la fa e vado
velocemente a farvi vedere ora così
resto Diciamo
nella
dove si vede un professore con una
normale valigia di pelle che
indossa è solo lui ha il superpoteri un
visore olografico
Visualizza un teschio per spiegare il
concetto di maxillo facciale e tutti gli
alunni vedono ciò che il professore sta
visualizzando e qui abbiamo vinto il
premio come la migliore soluzione
mondiale nell'ambito Education cioè
quello che voglio dire che intanto che
queste cose si possono fare anche a sud
non solo e non a New York o altre parti
e l'approccio è uno solo è quello della
tabellina Quindi quando mi chiedono 5 x
5 quanto fa e uno e non 25 chiaramente
scherzo Grazie
[Applauso]